i'm sasha loftis breaking tonight a
crash involving cars in north las vegas
kills at least five people this happened
this afternoon on cheyenne near commerce
street north las vegas police are giving
a press conference right now it's just
starting with an update let's take a
listen
[Music]
here we go
i am north las vegas councilwoman pamela
goings-brown and on behalf of the mayor
and this council
our thoughts and our prayers are with
the families who are experienced a
tremendous and unnecessary loss due to a
careless sense of act
our pd our firefighters and our other
first responders work tirelessly to keep
our community safe and when senseless
acts like this occur
it affects us all
so
i just ask that we keep this family in
our thoughts and our prayers
during this difficult time
and let's as a community
remain diligent
and safe and at this time i'm going to
turn it over to our police department
and our pio
officer alex cuevas
evening everyone my name is officer
alexander cuevas a-l-e-x-a-n-d-e-r
c-u-e-v-a-s i am the public information
officer for the north las vegas police
department i'm here to provide you an
update on the mass casualty traffic
collision that occurred earlier today
today at 3 pm officers received a
call about a traffic collision involving
multiple vehicles
in the area of cheyenne and commerce in
reference to multiple vehicles involved
in a collision
upon arrival officers did locate the
traffic collision
and with that i'm going to update you a
little bit more details
preliminary investigation revealed the
following a dodge challenger was
traveling northbound on commerce
approaching the intersection at a high
rate of speed upon that witnesses stated
that the dodge challenger did run a red
light and struck multiple vehicles
causing a chaotic event
as for the vehicles involved it involves
a maroon dodge challenger a white toyota
seneca
a white ford fusion a tan chevy malibu
a white hyundai tucson and a white
mercedes suv
some of the vehicles after being struck
were pushed into the north east lot
a vacant lot at that
of the intersection a total of 15 people
were involved in this incident
there has been a total confirmed of nine
deceased
ages ranging from young juveniles to
middle-aged adults
two people were transported to umc
in reference to their injuries
one person remains in critical condition
while the other one has succumbed to
their injuries
as for the
non-deceased the
injuries range between non-life
threatening to minor to serious
condition
speed is considered a factor in this
investigation as for impairment that
does remain unknown at this time
so as for the coroner they have arrived
on scene they will be releasing the
names and identities of the deceased as
well as the cause and manner of death
anyone with any information regarding
this incident is asked to call north las
vegas police department at 702-633-9111
and with that is there any follow-up
questions do you know approximately how
fast the driver was going because the
crash
at this point i don't have that
information but i will get back to you
as soon as i find that out you said two
people in the hospital
correct two people were transported to
the hospital umc but one has to come to
their injuries okay is one critically
injured yes out of those two yes
okay
do we know if the driver even tried to
slow down
at this point i don't have that
information
but it doesn't appear so from what i
have seen
do you have the approximate age of the
driver
i do not know that was officer alex
cuevas with north las vegas police
giving us an update on that deadly crash
at
commerce and cheyenne this afternoon
we're told it involved multiple vehicles
15 people involved that death toll now
up to nine it was originally around five
earlier in that update again they're
calling this a mass casualty traffic
condition at a catastrophic event we're
told that someone ran a red light ran
into multiple cars again 15 people
involved nine people dead one person
remains in critical condition at umc
they are asking anyone with information
to call north las vegas police they're
saying speed is a factor no word on
whether that original car that ran the
red light if that driver was impaired
now this again is still a developing
situation police are still investigating
so make sure to stay with eight news now
both on air and online for the latest as
this develops